Hello ! Donc
on va aujourd'hui parler d'un livre qui
s'appelle Finit in Infinite Game que je
trouve qu' est un bon pour qui est un
livre qui est bon dans le concept pour
justement les hommes dans vingtaine qui
veulent faire de quoi de leur vie. B ça
on va commencer. Euh souvent dans la
vie, tu joues pour avoir des certaines
adjectifs, surtout dans vingtaine. Là,
c'est genre euh OK, tu travailles fort
pour terminer tes études quand tu
termines, tu as ton diplôme, après ça
euh tu vas travailler full P pour avoir
euh le meilleur job possible. Donc, tu
vas avoir des CV, tu vas full travailler
fort. Tu vas travailler full fort pour
rencontrer des gens, avoir une blonde
puis avoir la meilleure blonde possible,
la meilleure relation possible. Après
ça, tu vas travailler full fort pour
avoir une augmentation de salaire, avoir
un meilleur poste, whatever. Tu vas
travailler full fort pour avoir une
maison, avoir une voiture, tu vas
travailler full fort pour vous comprenez
que un coup que tu atteins ces objectifs
là, tu arrives à un moment où que ben il
y a comme un vide. Tu as atteint ce que
tu travaillais fort, tu as atteint cet
objectif là puis c'est terminé.
Mais dans Infinite infit and infinite
game, c'est qui compare les deux. Donc
il a les jeux qui sont finis. Donc jeu
fini là, ça veut dire que tu joues pour
gagner, donc tu joues pour avoir un
certain objectif. Quand tu l'atteins,
c'est terminé. Les règles sont fixes et
fin et puis la fin est claire. Donc par
exemple règle règle fixe, tu vas
toujours à l'université à chaque jour
pour aller à tes cours, faire des
examens, avoir tes notes pour finir
avoir ton diplôme. Donc r clair fin
fixe, tu as ton diplôme, tu es diplômé.
Le but avoir un titre, avoir une
reconnaissance
euh soit un diplôme, un job, un salaire,
un statut, peu importe. Ça c'est avoir
un jeu. Ça c'est des jeux qui sont
finis.
Jeu infini. L'objectif, c'est ça qui est
important à regarder un mindset, c'est
tu joues pour continuer de jouer. Les
règles, il évoluent dans le temps. Il y
a pas de fin. Le but c'est grandir puis
rester dans le jeu. Puis ta vie c'est
entière. C'est ça fait partie de ta vie
entière dans fond. Donc qu'est-ce qui
est à comprendre là-dedans ? c'est que
d'avoir ta vie comme un infinite game,
de voir ta vie comme que tu as toujours
tu joues pour évoluer, tu joues dans ta
vie pour toujours repousser tes limites,
toujours essayer de créer de la valeur,
toujours t'améliorer dans tes dans tes
choses,
de voir ta vie comme ça pu pas les voir
en objectif fixe de je vais avoir ça, je
vais avoir c, je vais avoir ça, je vais
avoir parce que tu es toujours dans un
mindset lorsque tu es en jeu fini comme
Ça, tu es toujours dans le mind de désir
de je vais avoir ça, il me manque ça, il
me manque c il manque ça, je vais
travailler pour avoir ça. Un coup tu
l'as bon, il me faut d'autres choses, il
me faut d'autres choses, il faut
d'autres choses. Donc tu passes ta vie
toujours dans ce mindset de il manque
quelque chose pour être heureux. tandis
que le jeu infini, c'est le fait de
toujours travailler
pour t'améliorer puis de essayer de
créer un maximum de la valeur,
juste vivre le plus d'expérience
possible puis être dans le présent de je
suis heureux, je m'améliore. Mais dans
le jeu infini, tu vas en faire des jeux
finis. Donc c'est juste que tu vas faire
les jeux finis par exemple je sais pas
moi travailler ton diplôme à avoir une
maison blande peu importe mais tu vas
pas les voir comme un objectif final tu
vas les voir comme un processus
qui fait partie de ta vie qui te permet
d'évoluer de grandir puis d'apprendre
tu sais que tu qui gardé en tête
puis le problème quand tu confonds Euh
les deux les deux modes de jeu
quand tu crois que gagner des side quest
avancer les jeux qui jouent le jeu
infini entrent dans les jeux finis sans
tr
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire par
ça le problème quand tu ça mais au final
le comme je disais le le problème quand
tu confonds les deux c'est que tu vas
faire des jeux finis pu tu vas penser
que c'est ta vie, tu vas associer le
fait de toujours aller dans des de faire
des nouvelles side quest puis ça va être
ta vie.
Je sais pas ce que je vais ener avec ça,
mais
prenez pas les choses au sérieux trop.
La seule chose que à prendre au sérieux,
c'est ton moment présent dans ta vie en
ce moment même, est-ce que j'apprends ?
Est-ce que j'évolue ? Est-ce que je crée
de la valeur de plus en plus dans dans
ma vie ? Quand je parle de valeur, c'est
pas nécessairement faire de l'argent.
C'est apporter de la valeur dans la vie
des autres. Apporter de la valeur dans
ceux que tu côtois.
Apprendre, évoluer puis d'influencer
positivement les gens autour de toi.
C'est plus ça que je veux dire par là.
Euh puis ça principalement la société,
ça en fait partie de pourquoi on pense
en jeu fini. C'est c'est la société qui
te fait penser qui te fait avoir le
réflexe mental de penser en terme de
avoir ton diplôme, avoir un job, avoir
un salaire, avoir ta retraite puis
toujours attendre d'avoir quelque chose
de tout travailler pour avoir quelque
chose de plus qui te manque pour être
heureux. Mais ça c'est
la manière parfaite pour être
pas heureux vie.
Puis justement,
il y a un concept dans le lead qui dit
que
tu deviens une machine dans un système
quand tu fonctionnes comme ça. Quand tu
fonctionnes par jeu fini, tu deviens une
machine dans un système. Donc tu vas
atteindre un objectif puis tu vas juste
répéter ça. Puis tu auras plus de de de
quelque chose qui va t'allumer à
l'extérieur de toi. Il y a personne qui
il y a rien, il y a pas une mission. Il
y a pas un sens qui va t'allumer plus
qui va te pousser à te repousser à
repousser tes limites.
Puis il dit c'est comme si tu deviens
une machine à répéter répéter tout le
temps pu c'est là que tout pas son sens
au final c'est comme si tu as ton
diplôme tuas ton salaire ok là tu as
tout atteint ce que tu voulais tuas ta
maison tu as ta blonde tuas ton ch ta
tuas ton chien peu importe puis là ben
tu répètes tout le même stock que tu vas
faire tu sais tu vas voir c'est là que
le métro boulot dodo entre en jeu c'est
là que tu as plus de sens dans ta vie tu
as plus rien qui qui te pousse à
repousser tes limites tu v tout le temps
faire la même chose.
C'est là que tu rentres justement dans
le métro boulot dodo. Puis c'est là que
la majorité des gens arrêtent parce
qu'ils ont atteint le stade qu'il
voulait mais il arrêtent là puis ils
sont plus heureux par la sens leur vie
puis il deviennent des machines à
répéter.
Puis quand justement
je citer dans le livre dit lorsqu'une
machine fonctionne parfaitement elle
cesse d'exister.
Donc justement quand tu commences à
juste tout en faire des affaires pas
poser des questions, devient parfait
dans ce que tu fais, ben tu arrêtes
d'exister, tu es plus utile.
Donc pose-toi la question, est-ce que tu
es en train de devenir une machine
dans un système ? Donc tout répéter les
mêmes affaires d'atteindre un certain
niveau puis après ça devenir une machine
dans un système ou tu es en de cultiver
justement tes apprentissages de cultiver
ton expérience, ton vécu pour grandir et
faire des choses plus grandes encore
plus. Puis tu es-tu alimenté par quelque
chose de plus grand que toi ou tout le
temps je vais avoir cet objectif là, je
vais avoir c je vais avoir ça, je vais
avoir puis toujours être axé sur
je veux avoir tel affaire, je vais avoir
telle affaire, je veux réussir telle
affaire, je vais avoir parce que ça
c'est des objectifs qui sont finis mais
plus être axé sur le processus de
grandir, d'apprendre puis de repousser
tes limites.
Euh
donc je pense qu'on a fait le tour. En
gros, il y a peut-être plein d'affaires
que j'ai passé mais bon euh pour euh toi
demande-toi à la prochaine décision
importante que tu prends, pose-toi une
seule question. Est-ce que ça fait
est-ce que ça fait avancer mon jeu
infini ?
Est-ce que ça me pousse à savoir qui je
deviens ? comment que je grandis ou
est-ce que je cours juste après un titre
? Donc est-ce que en ce moment tu es de
faire des études juste pour atteindre un
certain titre, avoir de directeur VP
importe ou tu travailler pour avoir
telle relation pour avoir tel blonde
pour avoir telle affaire dans ta vie
pour avoir tel ch telle maison peu
importe tu es d'avancer ça avoir cet
objectif puis tu tu cours après pour
l'avoir
ou tu es en train vraiment plus de
j'apprends à être qui je suis puis j'éis
en de grandir, je d'apprendre à comment
que je grandis moi parce que tuas pas
besoin de changer tout de suite. Tu as
juste besoin de de besoin de voir les
deux jeux une fois que tu les tu vois,
tu joues plus jamais pareil.
Donc l'objectif c'est vraiment de savoir
qu'il y a deux jeux différents. Les jeux
finis qui sont pour avoir des titres,
des attestations, peu importe, avoir un
objectif qui est final puis de l' côté
que c'est juste le jeu de grandir.
Puis le jeu de grandir c'est ça faut
peut-être tu focuses le plus possible
dans ta vie.
C'est que tu vas devenir le plus positif
possible dans ta vie. Tu vas être
présent, tu vas apprécier le processus
tandis que l'autre tu vas être plus axé
sur le résultat puis le processus va
être en 2uxè.
fait que ça fait que tu vas tout le
temps penser réfléchir, tu vas être
moins dans l'appréciation du processus.
C'est sûr, c'est vraiment difficile.
Moi, je suis toujours en train de
travailler pour être axé sur le jeis, je
me développe mais il y a tout le temps
une partie parce que c'est tellement
facile de rentrer dans le je vais être
heureux quand je vais avoir ça, je vais
être heureux quand je vais avoir c, je
vais être heureux quand quand tout va se
mettre en place. Mais au final tu
repousses
tu repousses le moment où c'est que tu
vis pour de vrai. C'est un piège parce
que tu vas pas commencer à vivre dans 10
ans quand tu vas voir ta maison, ton
enfant, peu importe. Quand tuir ta
femme, tu vas être heureux. Tu vas quand
tu vas tu vas être heureux puis là tu
vas commencer à vivre. Là quand je vais
mes études là je vais commencer à vivre.
C'est pas quand je vais avoir mon mon
poste de VP, c'est là qu' va commencer à
vivre mais heureux. C'est live que tu
commences à vivre. C'est live que tu
dois mettre tes décisions, prendre tes
décisions. C'est live que tu grandis
c'est aujourd'hui même que tu prends les
décisions les plus importantes de ta
vie. Donc en être conscient puis de
prendre ces décisions en fonction de
je veux grandir, je veux m'élever, je
veux me je veux apprendre à me
connaître, prendre des décisions qui
sont de plus en plus en ligné avec qui
je suis.
Puis je crois que c'est comme ça que tu
vas être le plus épanoui. Puis quand tu
vas être sur ton lit de mort, tu vas
faire j'ai vécu une vie que je suis
fière puis c'était ma vie à moi. C'était
pas la vie de
la société voulait que me faire vivre.
C'était pas la vie que ma famille, la
culture, peu importe ma blonde, mon
chum, peu importe qui m'a fait fait que
j'ai eu cette vie. J'ai eu ma vie à moi
parce que j'ai décidé que c'était ma vie
puis je suis fier de l'avoir vécu comme
ça. OK,
j'ai je pense que j'ai ch donc salut Ok.